Today,
we have Dan Andrews who is trying to find water on the moon.
He's the project manager of the resource prospector program at NASA ames.
Without further ado,
here's Dan
[inaudible] for it to
be here.
I've been looking forward to this talk for some time.
Um,
a little quick note,
uh,
I was just at a conference in the UK and there was a whole bunch of discussions
about,
uh,
data analytics associated with Cubesat missions and,
and just in general.
And one of the,
um,
companies that was there was talking about the ability to judge how an economy
is doing based on the relative fill of a parking lot in an area or parking lots.
Uh,
you guys are doing just fine here.
It's tough to find parking.
All right,
so I'm here as a married indicated,
uh,
to tell you about the resource prospector mission.
It's a follow on mission to l cross,
uh,
which is a mission that it did indeed definitively.
Um,
note that there's water on the polar regions of the moon.
And I'll tell you a little bit about that,
a little bit about the whole Isr.
You Institute Resource Utilization Topic.
And then I'd like to,
uh,
focus probably about half the presentation on our status as a mission and some
of the cool development work that we're doing.
So,
first of all,
uh,
with respect to linear volatiles,
this has been a topic,
uh,
that has existed for a few decades,
but I'm featuring some of the notable missions that really helped to steer where
we are today.
The clementine mission,
which was not a mission,
trying to look for volatiles on the moon,
it actually had other,
uh,
multiple purposes,
but by static,
great.
Our testing of the polar regions of the mood indicated that,
wow,
there's,
there's some real high hydrogen concentrations in these polar regions.
Um,
and it was,
I think where some of the first thought went into could that actually be water?
Not that can't be water.
It's bone dry up there.
There's no way that can be water.
Lunar prospector,
which came around about four years later,
uh,
actually confirmed and measured the hydrogen levels.
But again,
the question persisted.
Is it elemental hydrogen is a hydrogen bound in the soil,
or is it hydrogen bound in water?
Uh,
you couldn't quite tell.
So what was needed was a mission like oh cross and we are co manifested with the
uh,
lunar reconnaissance orbiter mission that actually went in,
landed with vigor as we'd like to say,
uh,
with an impact or that went into a polar region.
Crater kicked up the soil that was there,
whatever's there was kicking it up into the sunlight and we had a shepherd in
spacecraft following behind it and measure what was in the soil.
And we were able to confirm,
uh,
quite a bit of water.
Ice.
Now on earth scale,
it's not quite a bit of water ice,
it's maybe of the scale of the Mojave desert,
lots of water.
However,
on a scale of both poles,
all the craters and all this truly trillions and trillions of gallons of water
potentially,
they're so great.
We answered the big question,
but so what the next step is to actually understand it on more human scales.
And that's where resource prospector comes in on the scale of maybe meters as
opposed to kilometers.
What's the nature of the soil,
uh,
of,
of the volatiles in the soil?
Is it ice and blocky form?
Is it instead fine like sand in there?
Is it,
is it higher concentrations here,
but lower concentrations there.
What about the role of the son plays?
So emission to go in there and actually understand the nature of the volatiles
is essential in the obvious next step.
So on the evolvable a Mars campaign,
and you could see a resource prospector right here,
the idea is that the big goal is Mars.
The big goal is to get boots on the ground in Mars.
However,
that's a very tough task and there's much that we could learn along the way.
And using the moon to our advantage,
um,
wound to our advantage can mean on a human scale,
uh,
what it's like to live and operate in a,
in a certain environment,
although the moon looks very different than,
than Mars.
Uh,
but it also can mean from a resource point of view,
which is really where my interest lies and where resource prospector comes in.
So I'm going to show you a mission,
a animation.
Um,
our original design is to go on say a [inaudible] and ELV say a Falcon nine
style to rocket.
This is us taking off from the Cape.
Um,
as an illustration Ferrin pops off for now on our way to the moon.
That's why he could see the lander and the rover there.
We just separated from the rocket.
We have a solid rocket motor on the bottom of the,
uh,
of the lander,
which is firing right here,
just finished.
And the whole point of that was to be captured by the moon,
right to not fly right by it.
So we use that to head in our,
uh,
critical descent trajectory.
I think at this point you're going to see the solid rocket motor kickoff.
We're done with that and now we start to reorient ourselves for the descent.
One thing of note here,
this looks probably like no other lander that you've seen before and that's one
of the key thrust of this mission that I'll get into in a little bit.
And that is we're trying to be very simple,
very risk tolerant and very cost effective.
Uh,
that's what El Cross was across the row,
rewrote the books on the moon for 79 million bucks.
Uh,
which on an Essa scales incredibly cheap for how important that mission was.
We're trying to extend some of that to a much bigger mission like resource
prospector.
So we go in,
we trim out our descent,
we get down to a slow fall rate and you can see here rover's ready to go.
The lander actually has two different ways that you can regress cause we don't
know that we might land partially on a rock,
um,
in some sort of obstacle away.
So we want to be able to double our chances to get off.
Now this is the resource prospector,
a surface segment we call it.
That means it's the rover and the payload system together because it can move in
all directions.
It can crab walk.
We immediately get on the sun to be power positive and then we can move in any
direction.
Of course at that point.
One of the big benefits of having the steering system that we have in this
arrangement,
which you're looking at here,
is an illustration of the neutron spectrometer system actually able to look
down,
say a meter through the soil without digging and actually look for indications
of hydrogen,
which would tell us where we might want to drop the drill and actually ground
truth that what that means is we're actually going into a permanently shadowed
region and by definition permanently shadowed it in it's two or three or 4
billion year existence,
has never seen the sun.
So the way you picture that is say if my head was the sun and this is the moon
as the moon's moving around the earth,
around the sun,
The sun light is all tangential to the polar regions.
So it actually shoots right over the top of some of these craters that are on
the polar regions that are very susceptible to be able to trap the water ice.
So we got to go down any of these areas that are actually maybe 50,
60,
70 degrees Kelvin,
maybe colder than Pluto and somehow have our machinery work.
So there's quite a bit of challenging that we are doing of ourselves right now.
Um,
so questions RP wishes to answer resource extraction needs to be economical.
Uh,
NASA won't get into the business of trying to,
uh,
provide resources,
at least not in the longterm.
That's the job of the commercial industry to figure that out.
But we need to answer some fundamental questions upfront in order for the
commercial world to be able to understand how tough for maybe easy this is going
to be.
So resource extraction must be economical.
What are the distribution of those,
of all those vertically and horizontally?
Um,
what's the overburden story?
Let's say you can't get to this water ice that we know is there,
but you have to drill down two meters to get it.
And it only exists in a permanently shadowed region,
not in a semi permanently shadowed region.
Uh,
that's a very different engineering problem than if it's littered on the
surface.
And you could just be scooping along the way and then putting it into a hopper
and baking it out.
These are questions we need to answer.
Um,
working environment.
All the same logic here,
son versus shadows,
soil mechanics,
traffic ability.
Is it easy to navigate over it?
Would you have these mobile platforms that can go in there and actually scooped
us up or is it more static?
So our job on our p is to take a look at four different areas.
This is our goal.
Um,
illustrate in the top right you could see a with color coding,
different types of environments in a given area,
in one of the polar regions.
And then the bottom right a illustrates a zoom in of those dry areas,
we really believe in the dryer is that are out in the sun.
There's not going to be any water.
I there and there may not even be water ice in the soil because it would have
over all those billions of years baked out from all the radiation and energy
being dumped into the soil from the sun.
But we're not sure that we just think that makes sense.
So we want to go try that out surface and permanently shattered regions that may
be literally on the surface.
We already have seen indications of frost from other missions.
Uh,
you know,
light weather,
like weather conditions,
if you will.
Even though this is an airless body,
a shallow,
I sit stable on the first centimeter first 50 centimeters versus 50 to a hundred
deeper.
All these things are,
uh,
answers that we wished to be able to get on this mission.
Our customer,
which is NASA headquarters in Washington DC,
um,
is it has really given us a really interesting framework.
Remember I told you we're a different kind of mission.
We're executing differently.
They gave us two requirements,
which I've synopsized here.
Okay.
They're pretty high level.
The whole goal is that they didn't want to give us incredibly stringent
requirements at level one,
as we call it,
because if you have any residual risk because you're trying to do things cost
effectively,
you could be a failure.
So they want to guide with the level ones and allow us to derive more detailed
requirements from that and take chances,
take a risk.
And in doing so we can be single strong,
which is our term for no redundancy,
right?
Test the heck out of the system,
go fly it and maybe accomplished something great like I'll cross for much less
money than would normally be required for a NASA mission.
So multiple paths to mission success,
uh,
call Rp,
lightweight risk tolerant,
cost-effective,
um,
mission.
Um,
I'm already finding that some of our early costs estimates are one third or
maybe even less.
The cost of a typical a NASA mission RP is not going to be a technical marvel.
So it was really hard for the engineers of which I am one that it's not going to
be this amazing achievement from a technical point of view where we're putting
the amazing or the marvel part,
um,
is in what it could answer.
But how we go about doing it should be as proven as we can possibly get it.
If we can get things off the shelf,
if there's things that have been demonstrated on other missions,
let's use them and then go do something great with that.
Including,
um,
influencing NASA NASA's methodology going forward,
which is a personal goal of mine.
Uh,
we are of course going to go after the minimum success first,
then we'd go for the full access and then we have fun.
Um,
and uh,
that could take a lot of different forms when we answer some of those
fundamental questions within one lunar day.
Do we,
when lunar night comes,
which may be depending on your location,
six to 14 days later,
earth days later,
um,
it'll get very,
very cold.
We're not required nor designed to make it through the night.
So do we just find a place that has the shortest night and then go sleep finally
and then come back in a earth week say and see if it comes back to life and we
can continue the mission.
Um,
Dewey just drive as far as we can into a permanently shadow region until we
can't communicate with it anymore.
Uh,
lots of different possibilities.
So let me talk just very quickly,
um,
about how the neutron spectrometry works in a very simple way.
Um,
I'm an engineer,
not a lunar scientists.
So,
uh,
this,
this is how I look at,
uh,
the opportunity here.
So galactic cosmic rays are continuously hitting the visible regions of the
moon.
And um,
in doing so,
they scatter the shadow of nuclear and you get all this flux that comes flying
out of the soil,
that neutron spectrometer that's sitting on the front and she saw very simply
animated with the um,
uh,
blue pathways and so forth in the video are what we're able to measure.
And if we find an area that's especially interesting,
you can see the neutron count rate there.
We could actually use our drill,
drill down to as much as a meter deep in the soil,
pull the material up.
And um,
in the video you would see that we actually cook the material.
We have a cleverly named device called an oven.
That's actually an acronym.
Um,
but it's also an oven that cooks the soil,
you know,
a crucible that we deliver into the oven,
cooks it and measures all the constituents that come baking off.
And so that's,
that's the whole key,
the whole trick behind the mission.
So we have a,
we set ourselves a very ambitious goal in fiscal year 15,
um,
that is can we actually from our requirements in a single year,
go from requirements to a preliminary design while going through all the gate
reviews that NASA has,
but a,
an expanded,
expedited version of them,
manufacturer the hardware,
build the hardware,
conduct testing on it,
and actually fly the mission.
Air quotes,
fly the mission on earth all in a year.
And so this was the rover that we had designed and uh,
I'll give away the answer.
We did it in a 10 to 11 months.
It was very impressive.
And so I'm going to walk you through now some of the work that we've done.
Um,
some of this predated the one year,
this is a little bit before,
but I want to use it to illustrate some of the work that we've done.
So what you're seeing here is the Krx rover at Nasa Ames Research Center out in
the rover scape.
And we've got the neutron spectrometer right up here in the front.
That's the one that you saw on the video and then a gamma ray source out in
front on this viscous that sits up front.
Because the beauty,
one of the many beauties of earth is that we have our atmosphere to protect us
from some of the radiation that we won't be protected from on the moon.
And so that's a radiation source,
low level radiation source that is pummeling the soil in front of the rover and
the Neutron Spectrometer can then take measurements as if it would out in the
native lunar environment.
We also have an instrument called nervous,
uh,
which is a near infrared spectrometer system.
So you've got a neutron spectrometer,
a near infrared spectrometer.
This one does not have the ability to look down in soil.
That's what the NSS is for.
This one has the ability to look at the surface like right on the surface.
And so what's very good about that is it allows us as we're cruising and doing
our mapping to see what's on the surface,
but also if we bring materials up to the surface,
we could look at what's coming up and actually get a vertical distribution of
what we're finding down at that drill point.
We then set up tests in a thermal vacuum chambers.
This is a soso image of a container,
say about a foot in diameter,
maybe about three feet tall that has been doped with a soil,
lunar simulant and a certain amount of water as a function of depth.
We put it in a thermal vacuum chamber,
take our drill system,
actually drill through it and see if we can recreate what we know is the shape
of the volatile distribution in that canister.
And this is a plot of what we had found in our data.
And it did indeed match very well to what was going on in there.
And that was at as near as we could reasonably get lunar temperature in a
permanent shadow region and add vacuum.
So that was a very good test you'd see here.
Uh,
the crucible,
uh,
that we're filling.
Um,
and this is the drill system,
bringing up materials and dumping it on the surface.
And that's where the near infrared spectrometer can take a look at it.
Now we're evolving the design a little bit further.
Here's the oven that Jose referring to.
You can see it's a red hot in here.
It's just truly a ceramic,
a double wound oven heating system in a scissor lift that pushes the crucible up
into it.
Um,
more development of the payload and drill system.
You see two videos on the right.
This is a two times sped up video of the processing of the crucible.
As it moves around after the drill has filled it.
Here's the drill,
here's the brush that knocks it into,
in this case of three d printed crucible.
So this is two times speed up testing all of our states,
um,
measuring stations,
putting on a cap,
taking off the cap and up top.
You could see us,
uh,
testing how the material comes off into these three d printed,
um,
crucibles and holders.
What you find is you see we're losing a lot of material over here.
This design needs to be improved upon and we since have improved on it.
But this is again why we're doing this activity.
It makes it very much,
it makes us much smarter with what we're doing.
Okay.
So the a rover that you saw,
the cat image of this is us starting to build it.
We're not building a flight rover.
Uh,
so for example,
the radiator system,
which is what that top deck is trying to represent is just aluminum.
There's no point to test our ability to radiate off heat and an earth
environment.
But we tried to make it physically representative the wheels and the control
system for steering and the suspension system is all relevant.
Although he had to robust some of the design up to work in one G.
Remember we've got one six g on the moon,
but to build the one six g item and then test it on earth may not give you
relevant results,
may even cause problems.
Uh,
heat spreaders where all the electronics are going so forth.
The dump,
the heat building up our battery banks,
um,
now revolving in a little bit further,
very pretty a suspension drive system.
We built five of these,
four of them for the rover,
and then one for testing,
uh,
including the driver boards.
Um,
uh,
these are the one g wheels,
which would look a little different and we've already evolved them since this
point.
But again,
this is the one your activity and starting to build this system together,
the chassis bones on each side.
Here you can see that oven system member of the video that we're showing
materials going back and forth.
That's the very device in there as a test unit.
Here's a commercial drill from a company called Honeybee that built a
engineering test unit for us.
They have lots and lots of experience out in a different analog environments
here on earth.
And so we're looking to them to provide that,
uh,
for the mission.
And here,
if you've been watching the date codes up top,
this is August a fiscal 15.
The year mark would be in the end of September.
And this is us driving around the rover at NASA,
Johnson and Houston.
And uh,
it gives you a real sense of scale there.
Um,
some of the steering possibilities,
you see the solar ray in that image there that again is mocked up a,
we really are running off a battery power which are really flight forward design
batteries,
but we charge it on an umbilical system before we went out there.
It's all umbilical free now though in this activity we use Wifi for the comm
system because we don't need to actually use a,
you know,
space-based comm system.
We don't need to prove that either.
That's all that's all well understood.
However,
that is the engineering test unit drill that's in there and inside of there is
that oven is our um,
lava system,
which is what sniffs the volatiles that come off of the oven.
Cs,
uh,
pushing ourselves on some of these slopes and over obstacles,
frankly beyond the requirements in some cases.
But we're challenging the design.
We're kind of beating this thing up.
I remember at one point we were up at the top of this hill and there was a
pretty sheer cliff and,
um,
we were looking to do,
you know,
a rotation and um,
one of the wheels nearly went off the edge.
All the lights flashed in my head and I thought I saw a tunnel.
Um,
and it ended up working out because one of the things you'll see in a video
coming up is we have the ability to redistribute the weight of the rover across
its four contact points.
So the wheels,
which could be a very,
uh,
important capability to be able to have.
So there is a still image showing you some of the piece parts.
I could see the a mocked up solar array.
Um,
you'll notice this looks very different.
Yeah.
Question.
Since,
since you were talking about the difference between one g and one sixth g
doesn't make sense to like no attention helium balloons or something to reduce
the weight.
Hold that thought.
Okay.
No,
we didn't do helium balloons,
but we,
we,
we took that same approach and you'll see that in a second.
But this doesn't look like any of the Mars Rovers,
not even a little bit.
I mean it's tall and the solar rays in the wrong place.
And what you're seeing here is,
uh,
the nature of the environment that we're going in,
which is a polar region on the moon.
When you think about that with my whole description,
my head being the sun and the moon and its orientation,
the earth and the sun.
Well the sun in particular never gets more than say seven or eight or nine
degrees above the horizon from a polar region on the moon.
So we have these incredibly long shadows and solar energy.
Since we're not nuclear or anything else,
it's going to come in nearly horizontal,
little bit off of horizontal.
And so our solar ray looking up to the sky,
uh,
it does nothing.
It's nothing but blackness of space up there.
And so the solar array has to be positioned.
You see it's on a near vertical.
It's playing to that reality of where the sun will be over the course of our
mission.
And then the a radiator system,
which this would normally be a not so good place to put that looking up into the
sun,
but again,
because of where we are,
it's going to be nothing but black up there.
So it's a great place to radiate off excess heat.
And then of course,
you've already seen the interesting way in which it moves.
That's all capability associated with us being able to navigate,
uh,
some social surprises over rocks and so forth.
Um,
yeah,
I think that's about it.
All right.
So I talked to you about some of the Mars Rovers.
Here's even some other,
uh,
rovers to give you a comparison with my crude PowerPoint capabilities.
These are roughly to scale from an image point of view.
You'd see the actual dimensions there.
Uh,
so we're,
even though we look very different than spirit and opportunity,
uh,
see all these,
you know,
foldout arrays and so forth.
We just don't look like that.
But we're roughly that size and this is 180 kilograms were heavier than that,
nearly double that,
a weight or you could also see some of the speed performance.
Although we're not trying to do a lunar speed record,
ground speed record,
but it's based on what we're trying to accomplish.
In the case of Luna Cod,
it was about,
you know,
getting some mileage,
um,
under its belt.
In our case,
we can go as fast as 10 centimeters a second while making that neutron
spectrometer measurement.
So we can measure on the fly.
We don't have to stop and measure,
but are,
uh,
runout speed is something closer to 25 centimeters a second if we're trying to
just get to another place.
Okay.
Or Julian in the rock yard.
And you can see here,
we actually took one of those crucibles that we had doped with lunar simulant
and actually buried it in the soil.
Uh,
that is not going to be at the right temperature.
We're in an atmospheric environment and so forth.
But we're trying to practice things like actually positioning the rover over an
area of interest.
Uh,
the movement they're in,
and then drilling and seeing how the process works while acknowledging we're in
a couple of environmental ways of quite different than what we'll see on the
moon.
It's all about learning.
And you'll see on the drill,
uh,
the flu to the drill is very interesting.
Neither of these pictures reflect,
I think the previous one showed it.
So if you go back and watch this,
you could see it.
The upper part of the drill bit has a flute that looks much more like an Auger.
So it's a very high pitch,
right?
This is the part that's actually trying to trap materials.
So has a very,
uh,
low sloped pitch.
So the material gets stuck in it.
The idea is that at the bottom of the,
of the drill bit,
when you go down there,
you're trapping materials in there.
But as you keep going further,
you want to move the materials up and out through the auger system.
So you're trying to pass material up and out.
But this is the area where you want to trap it and then you pull it back up out
of the ground.
So here's the trap soil.
And then this brush system is wiping out those flutes where the materials trap
that falls down into the crucible.
And then over here is a crucible shown inside the oven.
But it would actually be going out through those brushes going out there to
receive the material outside of the oven and then come back in and do the magic
you saw in the video with running around into the oven,
measuring before,
measuring,
after putting a cap on it,
all those different activities.
Uh,
Houston,
uh,
so this was in the middle of summer,
despite how that looks and these things come up on you pretty quick.
You see clouds off in the distance and then suddenly this is happening to you.
This was our lead systems engineer.
You just came back in his car.
He did run out into this.
He was a hero along with other guys.
But this tent you see here is actually a cooling tent because it's so stinking
hot and humid there.
And so,
uh,
there's a big air conditioner system in there and it's,
it's so hot.
It's so miserable during mid day that,
uh,
you have to go in there and just chill and there's water in there.
So this is the tent that right now you see as almost being folded in half by the
wind and the temperature isn't actually a problem here.
We got water that's going inside the tent and you'd see water's pooling around
the feet.
Uh,
guys who are out there conducting the test actually had to make little dams
around the a rover in and a few guys that were hanging on the tent to keep it
from lifting,
um,
hero.
And then once it cleared and that's,
that was literally,
you know,
45 minutes later,
I look at the sky,
beautiful,
cloudy but clear sky.
And then we took it back and it was all fine cause the guys were,
uh,
a lot of locals there understand how the weather works,
but it's pretty impressive to us.
So the culmination hearing I'm out in Noah's that August 21st,
um,
culmination of the work was to actually do the mission,
right,
uh,
on earth.
And so what we did was in the top left picture here,
this is at Ames research center.
You may know Jay and some other folks who are actually with very low cost,
you know,
mission construct.
It doesn't look like what you used to seeing in the movies and that's by design.
This is just a bunch of pcs network together.
Um,
we're doing the overall mission operations role and then down here is at Kennedy
Space Center in Florida.
That's actually firing room for,
for anyone who understands all the different firing rooms there.
This is a pretty expensive well outfitted place that they put a,
the simple setup in.
They are in control of the payload that's on the rover.
We're driving the rover around the honeybee drill that I told you about.
It's actually being monitored at a Pasadena and this is actually taking place in
Houston.
So yes,
the distances are all wrong.
If you're on the moon,
it's much more challenging.
But we're behaving and operating two procedures that are essentially what we
would expect to do on the mission.
We didn't give ourselves a breaks.
I mean we did in between different scenarios,
but we really did a real time scenario there.
This is one of my favorite pictures from the whole activity.
You'll notice an interesting framing.
There's,
there's a big hill that uh,
at one point I thought we were nearly going to fall off of.
So you've got to check in his phone.
Uh,
any idea what is framing that this image of the black above and below
those are sunglasses.
So it happened is we hadn't fully calibrated the,
uh,
imaging system and we went out there and that bright Houston,
light,
we had a whiteout conditions.
And so one of the engineers are there sacrifices.
Oakley's snapped it in half the camera,
you know,
lenses.
The eyes are this far park.
You couldn't just put a pair of glasses on,
snapped him,
duct taped them.
Part of the drama that you can't see if there was a piece of duct tape here that
was holding each one on.
And as the heat was going on,
we're all at Ames research center.
I think I'm sitting right over here and we're watching it.
And you could slowly see the tape starting to peel away.
Is it going to drop?
Is it again?
Uh,
it ended up working great type innovation we won't be able to do on the moon,
but it shows the character of the people who are,
uh,
involved.
And then finally,
another fun picture do of our project scientists,
Tony Color print and Rick Elphick.
Um,
you can see the ric is wearing a blue red three d glasses and getting,
you know,
striking,
quite opposed.
He's actually looking at the information that's coming off of the camera that
looks down at the soil.
We have different led sources designed into it and so we could turn it on and
off different ones.
And by overlaying the data of those and then comparing it,
uh,
you can actually get an interesting 3-d and,
scientifically relevant information off of that.
Let's you see things through a different light.
I think over the course of the testing we found m and m's,
uh,
we've found paperclip.
Um,
I had a guy go and take some water and throw it over here and not tell the team
who was operating it to see if they came across it.
We didn't end up venturing over there,
so we couldn't say we found water.
But we found m and M's.
Um,
and some other things with the official equipment driving tools.
this is one of my,
my favorites.
It's a,
it's called verve and you can see just the level of fidelity that you have
represented in the model,
but also the terrain.
The terrain is very relevant,
a good representation of that area and the um,
uh,
rock yard over there at,
in Houston.
And,
uh,
I was just watching the rover driver work with them as it was very intuitive,
um,
how you basically pick and place and do your way points and uh,
as as so it's very impressive or developing new capabilities there that are
being,
that will be used on other missions as well.
Okay.
So helium balloons,
this was our version of helium balloons.
You can see the black strapping here on each side.
Uh,
you'll see it again,
but basically on each side and then going up with some,
you know,
ties up to the ceiling.
This is in a microgravity type test facility.
It's called the Argos facility and we can dial in the gravity that we want.
So what you're watching here is traction testing and navigability.
There you can see the yellow strap going up in one,
six g.
So this is representative of the moon,
although that soil there happens to be just sand.
Um,
and we're challenging ourselves at different angles to see what the grouser
design looks like for the wheels.
And we even played with two different lander regresses to different lander
designs.
This is quite a steep one,
not like what you've seen in the video,
but some of our potential partners have posed tall landers,
which means you have to navigate this.
This is also in that facility,
could still see the yellow strapping.
Um,
and believe it or not,
this looks completely rigged.
Like it's been held back.
This is in free rotation right now,
but at one six g and it's the aluminum treads on the aluminum slow pair,
which is not an engineered,
um,
uh,
slide if you will.
Uh,
but you're just getting aluminum to aluminum biting.
So it's actually,
this is not artificial despite how and counter intuitive it is.
It looks like it's being held back somehow,
but it's not.
And then I think there's one final one coming off of a lander deck that's very
similar to what we expect from our lander design that we're currently working
with.
Okay.
So this illustrates of the navigability of the suspension system and watch what
happens right here.
Now that was a more of a tuning issue than anything else.
So at first that you should not be impressed,
but it illustrates an important thing.
Um,
it's the ability to be able to redistribute the weight of the rover on to say,
you know,
three of the wheels.
Uh,
why does that matter?
Well,
for obstacles potentially and stuff.
But the,
the really interesting thing,
one of the many interesting things about l cross was in those permanently
shadowed regions when we impacted and we knew when we impacted,
uh,
we can measure it,
there was no impact for those of you who watched when El Crosswind,
it was a big nonevent where's the light shining out?
Where's the big explosion that should come out of there?
Well,
on the spectrum of what could have happened on El Cross,
that's one bookend.
The other book end though is one where the softest Downey Talc is in those
permanently shadowed regions.
And so when we went in with the El Cross impact her,
it was a good fraction of a second before there was a thermal signature that was
measurable at 5,600 miles an hour,
a fraction of a second,
like three quarters.
Second is very deep.
A lot of distance has occurred at that speed.
This is spawned a whole bunch of science associated with the nature of those
permanently shatter regions.
Because think about it,
there's no thermal cycling going on.
Um,
it's very,
very cool.
The principal,
uh,
forces at play,
maybe electrostatic.
And so there's been premises put out there,
you know,
electrostatically stacked Adams,
that are just this cush for when it came in.
So how do you navigate that with a rover?
And so we don't know what that looks like when you're in the sign.
You've got well consulted soil.
Are you going to,
as the moment you have this,
we'll go in and sort of fall to your belly as a rover.
Not Likely.
There's likely to be a transition,
but we,
we don't know.
Nobody knows.
And so the ability to have,
uh,
the capability to move around and distribute weight,
maybe pull yourself out of an area that you got stuck in and back away and then
redistrict yourself,
uh,
might be worth every penny that that costs.
So these are conversations we're having,
including the nature of the,
uh,
permanent shadow region,
seeing here thermal vacuum testing going on here of some of the robotic systems,
not the whole rover,
but some of the key mechanical systems at temperature at vacuum.
Got Some still images to,
uh,
of course,
true biology,
the nature of grease and oil and so forth.
In these environments is very relevant,
uh,
preventing offgassing or dealing with it
with the materials that you choose.
Here's vibe testing.
It doesn't look like much is happening in the video,
but if you look very closely it is vibrating.
Yeah.
So this is random vibe and various configurations.
This happens to be in the launch.
You see the drill is stowed tucked down to the right and we're,
we're just trying to see what happens to the system and even the individual
subsystems that you've seen some of these other photos at vibe.
This is on yet another test of the viability of your system.
And as is the case in many missions,
the harshest environment it'll see is notch.
And so for example,
when we were talking about wheel design and one six g,
um,
we actually have to design a system for well beyond what we expect to need on
the moon just to survive launch.
And that's just the nature of things until we start launching off of other
planets where it might be an easier go at it.
And of course looking at a stereo vision testing.
Uh,
this is a very strange environment that we're in here because the sign is so low
on the horizon,
the shadows are very long.
So black,
the blackness of a shadow that has no atmospheric,
you know,
cross lining,
it's very binary.
So you've got whites and you got blacks and you got whites and you got blacks.
How do you tell the whole from a shadow,
I do tell a hill from a shadow,
from something over there that very,
very difficult to do inexpensively.
You can bring a lot of money to bear and start having laser based this and that
and so forth,
which maybe we will end up doing.
But again,
against the premise of doing things cost effectively,
this,
this represents in a special engineering challenge,
you listen carefully,
you could hear almost a music going on in the bottom right.
This is our land or prototype,
a cad model,
top left and actual built model and the right.
And then this is a video of us doing cold flow testing.
So we're actually running water through the thrusters in different pairings.
So it's bouncing around the thrust right now.
And then we have,
you know,
just pipe to carry the waterway.
And so it's allowing us to just play with timing and then a kind of violent
ending and that's where we were firing them all pretty quickly.
Uh,
but again,
it's just a,
a novel aluminum riveted structure that we're testing out the avionics,
um,
at some level thrust or control.
So to,
uh,
to close resource prospector overview,
we're about the nature and distribution of the water and trying to move the ball
so to speak,
down down the field a little bit further.
This is what you can expect.
This is what you have to contend with.
And even testing a little bit of that excavation and processing.
When we bake off that stuff,
we're going to capture some oxygen,
are going to capture some other volatiles.
Um,
that could be a very early step to what would end up being required.
If you are a commercial business coming in and looking to drop pallets all over
the surface or down in a permanently shadowed region,
run,
run on some sort of uh,
devices going.
It's filling bottles with leaders of oxygen,
leaders of hydrogen,
and then NASA and other companies come and buy it by the leader and you're
creating a whole new,
you know,
economic opportunity and their business.
Uh,
so this is,
this is perfect use taxpayer bucks.
Um,
RP specs.
you can read it yourself,
but there's that mission life that I was talking about.
It all has to do with the lighting.
Um,
we can make this a much more expansion mission and go somehow nuke or something.
You could survive the night,
but we don't believe we need to do that to answer the fundamental questions.
This isn't about engineering.
Elegance is about answering the questions and there's this,
I think a certain elegance in that in itself,
our timeline,
a phase,
a formulation that was really where we're conceiving of the idea.
Then this demonstration,
Rp 15 is what I just described to you.
All that testing that we did in a single year.
Now we're,
uh,
we are doing the environmental testing and 16,
that was the thermal vacuum chamber testing,
the slopes facility testing,
the,
uh,
vibration testing and a number of other things that I didn't show here.
And so fiscal 17 is what we're in now.
Our fiscal year started in October.
And so we're targeting having our system requirements review at the end of this
fiscal year,
which is September of 17,
and moving out as a mission.
That's what we're currently targeting.
You can see current launch date and so forth.
So that can't wait to go.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
in such a low temperature with your oils get stuck or stick until the ground.
Like,
I don't know,
like,
uh,
what's kind of physics would be expected in such a low temperature?
Yeah.
This,
this is a,
this is a fair question and this is why we're doing all that testing in
different forms.
We would ideally have a place where we could represent all the lunar conditions,
have lunar simulant,
have the temperature's correct,
have the,
um,
uh,
vacuum conditions correct.
And bring the whole rover in there.
That's unlikely it be,
that would be a very expensive thing to do in a very big thermal vacuum chamber.
We could maybe do it,
but it's a challenge.
So what we're trying to do is some of what you've seen here,
which is take pieces of it and see,
um,
see how that works.
If through our risk management process,
we determined that,
um,
it's sketchy enough where these conditions and those conditions,
if they combined together,
we might have a really bad day.
When you go to roll off of that lander,
we may be forced to do more extensive testing.
Uh,
but we'll see.
We're in the middle of evaluating that.
Uh,
so how again,
do you redistribute the weight around the rover?
It's all about the mechanical positioning of the,
um,
of the suspension system.
So you can lower,
say these are my four wheels.
You could lower back corner,
just kind of sit back and that allows you to pull this one out and maybe you can
navigate back under that awkward pose and then reposition yourself and recenter.
There's even a,
a strange possibility that I would not call this a designed in feature,
but you could such potential articulation,
take the wheels and actually move them into an orthogonal orientation where
they're not rotating and depending on what the locomotion looks like.
And I,
I'm,
I'm just imagining here,
you could potentially have some form of walking out of it.
If the traction properties are successful,
uh,
that's not,
like I said,
a designed in feature.
But if we find ourselves in a position where,
ah,
this is really a bad day,
then you have the possibility of exploring options.
Uh,
is that redistribution done manually or automatically?
Yeah.
So,
um,
we that would be done manually on the ground.
Um,
you know,
there's a sliding scale of autonomy,
a fully autonomous system,
which this is not.
And then a fully tele operated system,
which this is not,
um,
uh,
we gave way points for our navigation,
which means there's some self guidance if you will,
along the way.
Autogeneration but this is closer to a tele type approach than,
uh,
than something fully autonomous.
And when you think about it,
a Mars has a very different,
it's very different in many,
many ways,
but one of them is just transport time,
communications,
transport time that the moon has pretty,
pretty tight,
pretty short transport time.
So it allows us to do things with the benefit of humans in the loop that are not
really feasible.
You have to script everything for,
for the Mars missions just because of speed of light.
And so,
um,
we're trying to play to that because again,
elegance isn't what we're after here.
We're just trying to answer the questions and if the best way to do a short six
to 14 day mission is with a bunch of people getting tired,
but we can all survive doing that 24,
seven was shifting and so forth,
then we should do that.
And that's what we're doing.
Yes.
I noticed that,
um,
some of the wheels you had in the demos looked more like a gears.
It seems that they would get sort of really good traction and these look like
they're kind of shallow treads that don't look like they would work very well in
some of the sandy environments.
So what's with the,
yeah,
so the,
um,
the ones that you saw in the pretty video,
and I think the one here,
um,
our,
our Chevron shaped right.
And,
uh,
they were an initial stab at what might work in an environment.
We found that it worked,
uh,
pretty,
pretty poorly and sand you and sought gunking up and so forth.
The testing that we were doing on the slope and the microgravity facility,
uh,
frankly just had angle iron on it and it was looking at things like the depth of
the grouser and the spacing of the browser to just try to get,
uh,
some sort of heuristic sense of what's going on.
But,
uh,
that's really as far as it would go because there's so much about that testing
that isn't relevant.
Like it isn't lunar simulant at the correct,
uh,
dryness and in a microgravity environment.
So we still have much testing to do.
So.
Except that,
yes.
So is there any chance that the data collected by this mission could be used for
a surgeon,
for traces of life or pest life,
perhaps in sort of,
uh,
extreme of files in this region?
So,
uh,
I'm always impressed this happened on elk cross to where you set up to do these
five things and that's what you designed the instruments forward to do these
five things.
And then someone comes along and says,
you know,
if I take half of that and correlate it with this,
I could actually pull out this other information.
So we're not attempting to do what you're describing.
It's all about volatiles.
But if we can measure the carbon compounds and some other things,
I don't know what might end up being possible,
but it is,
it is not our intention.
It's really about resources.
It's more of a,
an exploration mission as opposed to a scientific mission.
Even though we're using science to answer some exploration questions.
It is,
however,
we think that a learning from this is extensible to other places,
asteroids to Mars and so forth,
not the specific conditions.
Um,
there's no atmosphere here.
And you know,
so much about is different,
but the methods of uh,
getting to the or processing or might have great extensibility to other
capabilities and the case of asteroids,
the moon might be actually a very good analog,
no atmosphere,
they're reduced gravity.
Um,
yeah,
it might be,
might be a very good example.
So we think this has extensibility even if you don't care about the moon at all,
I think we'll be maturing the sort of the TRL,
the technology readiness level of a bunch of technology that will benefit going
forward.
The Detroit to drill inside caves on earth to see how uh,
places that have never seen light of day correlate to places on the surface.
So you know what to expect on the,
those bases on the moon.
The correlation of Earth Cave Areas I think would be a little bit unclear with
respect to the moon.
What we were attempting to do when you saw those canisters,
the large canisters by say a meter tall,
um,
was recreate what we believe is the case on the moon with lunar simulant.
And then we engineered the doping levels so that we could confirm if we could
see it and even the compaction level.
And we've even played with cases where we doped it with certain,
you know,
rock counts and sizes and so forth.
So I don't think we need to go to a,
uh,
natural terrestrial cave area to attempt to mimic what we think we'll see on the
moon.
We actually are able to create it.
Now the open question is do we actually understand what we're going to find
there?
And so trying variations on a theme is hugely important because when we discover
that,
guess what,
we didn't actually know what the way we thought we did.
Does the drill breaks?
Does the drill gets stuck?
Does it get kicked with a rock?
Does it get jammed?
And I don't have spare fluted bits in my back pocket as a rover,
a game over.
Do you need to have a way to pop off that drill?
So as you can at least still scan?
These are all things we have to be very deliberate with.
But,
um,
I think,
we have that handled.
So the results that you might find a drilling or are those typically made
publicly available?
In some sense,
yes.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one of the
really great things I think,
um,
about NASA frankly.
And that is a while it's,
it's a u s endeavor.
Uh,
it's partnered in some cases with internationals.
And so there's multiple players in there.
In the end we make this stuff available to mankind.
Right?
And so the,
uh,
I think that's for the overall good.
But the other thing it brings from more selfish point of view,
if you get more mines on it,
right?
You get a bunch of different people thinking in different ways on the problem.
We don't have a corner on,
on all the smarts out there.
So bringing the whole community to bear on,
on data and how you look at the analytics of it I think is a very powerful.
Um,
yeah,
you guys are probably focused on the current mission,
but I'm,
I'm curious to know based on the outcomes of this and the findings.
Um,
so you do find water and a good enough distribution that it might be worth
following up on what type of missions in the next 10 to 20 years might we see
that we,
you know,
we could be looking forward to
yeah.
So,
um,
under the presumption that we have at least semi favorable results,
meaning we find that the water or maybe other interesting things are available
and accessible from an engineering point of view,
which I suspect will be the case.
We're very water centric,
but it doesn't just have to be about the water three maybe for,
yeah.
So,
um,
I think what the next missions will look like,
and I,
I'm approached all the time by the commercial world,
um,
saying that they would do a small scale excavation activity in a,
from a water point of view and a juicy area in an area where it's relatively
easy,
whatever that means to get at it based on the RP data.
And then I think that sort of creates a pathway to bigger and bigger scales.
You could actually envision mobile systems eventually,
but you're going to start probably with something that looks a little bit more
like a pallet that's placed specifically in a very desirable area.
Um,
and I think the government and the commercial side,
we'll be working together on this because while we answered this question and
maybe that now opens up an opportunity for the commercial world to go exploit
and make profitable enterprise out of that,
the large scale,
uh,
possibilities going as a next step might be something that's more suitable for
government level risk taking and dollar amounts and then that will feed the
next.
So I see this kind of inch warming thing going up towards,
uh,
really a holistic in situ resource utilization capability.
Uh,
could you assemble the,
uh,
influenced,
will polluted by a asteroids or comets that's flight
through moon and how did you differentiate those?
So I'm not gonna be able to answer how you differentiate commentary stuff or
asteroidal stuff from other things.
But absolutely,
there's lots of impact gardening going on.
I love that term.
I did not make that up,
which is because there's no atmosphere on the moon or at least a very,
very tenuous one that is not protecting the surface like we do on earth.
Um,
surface is riddled with them.
Impregnation of materials that have been brought there,
um,
over a few billion years.
Uh,
it's even,
and I'll postulated that some of the big water fines in some of these
permanently shadowed craters may well be the leftovers of asteroids or comets
depositing on the moon since the moon's formation likely didn't allow water that
was found at that time to somehow survive.
So it's probably all deposition.
So now there's yet another marketing opportunity right by and moon water.
How much,
how much do you think this would cost and lunar water?
Right?
Uh,
so,
um,
I,
I think there's just untold possibilities here.
Even on the commercial side,
we're hearing,
I speak a lot to the Google lunar x prize,
a competitor's.
I went to the annual meeting last year and there's all sorts of rich ideas on
what to do very explicitly with the material,
but also almost symbolically,
um,
you know,
bringing things from Earth there and so forth.
There's lots of,
uh,
exploitable possibility here.
So you said the mission is during the lunar day,
um,
but wouldn't driving down to the craters,
make the environment pretty similar to the Luna night?
Temperature wise
will be from a temperature point of view,
but the,
uh,
the idea is we can get back out.
So we have batteries in the sizing of the batteries and the sizing of the whole
power system are very much driven by that point.
So can we go in there and spend,
say five,
six hours in zero power,
positive conditions,
just using the batteries and actually operate a drill,
bring it up.
Um,
in the video unfortunately cutoff,
but in the video we,
for example,
don't do processing down there.
We don't cook it.
That's an energy pig.
So we get the material and we get out of there,
we get back out in Sun,
turned her back on the sun,
get power positive and then start cooking the system.
So,
um,
it is similar from a temperature point of view,
but we still have come back to earth because even though you're in this
permanently shadowed region,
we're designing the system to always be able to see earth,
to be able to,
you know,
send our signal there.
Um,
and to be able to navigate out because I pointed out were,
you know,
a little more like a tele off then we are like a fully autonomous system.
Um,
so yeah,
that's,
that's designed in,
that's intended.
It does put a challenge on our mechanical systems design and power systems
design because it's very cold.
So about that,
about having the river always need to go from the dark place back to like did
recharge and back,
have you considered having two or three rovers?
One to just keep recharging the other one in the dark and it could also
communicate with that one so it doesn't actually have to be facing earth thin.
Okay.
There's even ideas out there,
um,
of umbilicals that go to something that's up on the surface,
that's enjoying sign all the time.
Those are all completely viable ideas and they may fit more into the paradigm of
what you would do in a production sense,
right?
If it turns out,
say that the water or the accessible waters all down in that,
you know,
70 degree Kelvin area.
So it's tough.
Well,
yeah,
the rim of that creator is likely going to be loaded with all sorts of power
generation capability and at least you'd be able to go up there and sit and park
in charge and you'd have a whole arsenal of these things going down there.
That's all possible in our case that I remember our paradigm.
We're trying to just answer the questions and if we think we can answer those
questions about the nature of things in a simpler way that keeps our complexity
in check keeps therefore our likelihoods of failure in check.
That's what we're going to pick.
Um,
so,
uh,
I take it you've heard of the men bill stone and the Shackleton Energy Company
at all.
Um,
what are your thoughts on that as a future venture and a,
I mean,
is this like the next oil economy of the space,
age of the solar system,
age?
I think all of that as possible.
I won't talk about any particular company,
but I have,
I have spoken with them at most recent conference I went to,
uh,
despite water being very interesting.
I had two different presenters from two different companies who I didn't speak
with directly at all site RP as an important mission because it's answering
questions so that they can do very clever things such as,
um,
actually,
you know,
scooping up the soil,
they're putting it into this magical hopper and outcome,
crucibles filling with copper,
crucibles filling with iron,
crucibles filling with,
you know,
aluminum and so forth.
And then you turn that into feed stock for three d printing and interesting
public private partnership up.
Oh,
absolutely.
And,
and the government would benefit from having that capability up there.
It could be a profitable enterprise.
So the commercial side does this is a win,
win,
win.
Absolutely.
And I think it starts with a mission like this.
All right.
Thank you.
[inaudible].